en el mundo la conocen como la reina de
la natación en aguas abiertas
doce medallas en campeonatos mundiales y
seis veces galardonada mejor nadadora
del mundo respaldan el título en su
vitrina sólo falta el sueño dorado la
medalla olímpica un reto pospuesto por
la pandemia que puso un freno a su
rutina y golpeó duramente a su país
estoy en busca de esta medalla
que me falta pero
yo creo que es cosa de la conciencia y
cuando tenía que acontecer
pudo retomar sus entrenamientos gracias
a la denominada misión europa que le
permitió viajar a portugal para
internarse en el complejo deportivo río
mayor o se ocupa de recuperar el tiempo
perdido pues el secreto del éxito
insiste es entrenamiento y disciplina
entrenadas no es sólo es llegar aquí y
hacerlo entrenamiento entrenar es todo
desde ahora que tú despierta que comes
cuando descansar como una marcel acción
al menos 300 atletas del comité olímpico
brasileño los beneficiados con el
convenio pudiendo volver a su rutina en
uno de los complejos deportivos más
importantes de toda europa donde el
hobby 19 no ha podido frenar la
preparación para los juegos olímpicos de
tokio 2021 preguntábamos sin esfuerzos
porque contamos aquí esfuerzos para
conseguir en tiempo récord de montar
esta mega operación y traer a este grupo
de atletas a portugal comenzaron a
llegar en julio y se quedarán
aproximadamente hasta diciembre
aproximadamente de siembra 36 kilómetros
entre capri nápoles marcará el retorno a
la marcela las competiciones el próximo
6 de septiembre
su participación será una vez más en
homenaje a el tricampeón de fórmula 1
aire conocen a su ídolo
esta vez el principal reto será vencer
las secuelas que ha dejado la pandemia